that was super super ridiculously sour I
thought it would be a really funny idea
to go around the office and test
people's sour candy threshold so I went
looking for the sour candy in the world
I couldn't get my hands on it but I
found the next best thing these bad boys
they're actually from the UK they're not
even available in the US so I'm gonna go
around and see what people think let's
go what's your relationship with
barricading do you like it I usually
like sour candy not like crazy sour
stuff you know I'm very sensitive to it
I don't know why people will put
themselves through the pain sour candy
first of all should not be called sour
candy it should just be called sour
pieces there's can't stands I know my
show not at all I find it extremely
painful and it hurts my whole mouth I
used to love sour candy but now I'm
afraid of it things like a tiny pink
munchkin donut large marbles it looks
like a bouncy ball that's been coated
and illegal it's pretending to be sweet
but it's like poison this is safe though
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm they're like a warhead on steroids
you swallow it burns your throat it's
like when they put the vacuum in your
mouth the dentist to suck all the
moisture out what's going on with this
like battery acid it tastes like what I
imagine cleaning fluid it tastes like
detergent yeah you like a punishment
like someone shot a machine gun in my
face
that's either a hole in my tongue I got
through it and then I bit into it and
then it started foaming and I felt like
I had rabies I spit it out in my cup of
water and it's like fizzing in here
that's what's doing in your stomach
right now
yeah Bruce are Zambezia nvb okay so I
was told by my colleagues that it's only
fair that I try this as well
[Music]
[Music]